[Music]
so far no one has actually ever seen a
black hole and so we were able for the
first time to actually take an image of
a black hole and make it visible to
everyone what you have to do is to build
a telescope that's able to see a mustard
seed in New York as seen here from
Europe and to do this you have to create
a telescope the size of the world this
telescope is a hundred meter in diameter
but it's not enough you want a bigger
telescope of course it's impossible to
build but you can create a virtual
telescope so what we do is we combine
telescopes all over the world into one
big telescopes observing at the highest
radio frequency if you can observe and
then you can see the shadow of a black
hole
[Music]
I think the funding from Europe made all
the difference it helped us to make a
big impact in the entire project I'm
proud of Europe because we have invested
so much in this project we have put all
together more than 44 million euros
because we can be proud that Europe has
a winning formula and that winning
formula is simple we believe deeply in
the freedom of science we believe that
scientists are the ones to make the
choices that the choices of science are
not done by politicians we believe
somehow in the intuition of science
[Music]
you